[Music]
straight ahead all law and crime daily
more delays in the prosecution of
so-called doomsday cult mom
lori valodebel we break down the charges
and allegations
it's clear that we're all just making
our best guesses as to when we can start
having jury trials again
one of america's most prolific serial
killers has died
the cases samuel little admitted to and
the ones still unsolved
putting his hands around a woman's
throat and choking her out to him that
was sex
plus why the irs is taking the estate of
prince to court
and prosecutors want to keep undercover
video of new england patriots owner
robert kraft
howe's defense is trying to get evidence
of the supposed sex act
destroyed law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a trial date for the so-called doomsday
cult mom has been pushed back
you know brian this isn't for the top
charges against lori valo day bell
she's facing two separate cases in
connection with the deaths of her two
children
yet none of the charges are from murder
lori valo and her husband chad dabell
are charged with concealing and
destroying
evidence while valo's children were
reported missing
authorities discovered the bodies of j.j
and tyler ryan
buried in shallow graves on daebel's
property in fremont county idaho
police arrested the couple in hawaii
last year
valo is also facing three misdemeanor
charges of
obstruction solicitation and contempt in
her hometown of madison county
they stem from allegations for lying
about jj's whereabouts
like apparently asking her best friend
to cover when police asked to see
the seven-year-old boy this trial is now
expected to take place
after the couple's first trial this
summer
i received on december 8th motion
and stipulation to vacate the trial
setting in this matter from mr means and
mr wood
that was closely followed by the supreme
court order of december 14th
prohibiting any jury trials from
occurring
until further order so that essentially
also vacated our january trial setting
date
and then this morning mr means i
received from you a waiver of speedy
trial
with your client's signature and then
i see that the felony jury trial for ms
valo
is currently set for july 12 to continue
through
august 6th the week-long misdemeanor
trial is now scheduled to begin
on august 30th just weeks after the
felony trial
you can see there's a lot of scheduling
there thanks terry and this is just for
lori valo right
yeah that's right brian the august 30th
trial is just in connection with the
misdemeanor charges against
laurie the obstruction solicitation
contempt charges those were levied
against her because
first of all she lied about jj's
whereabouts and then she asked melanie
gibb
to lie and she failed to produce her
children so yes this is just in
connection with lori valo
gotcha and to be clear this will be
about what happened before the bodies of
the children were discovered
joining us now is professor and forensic
death investigator joseph scott morgan
joseph always a pleasure to have you
here joseph good to be here with you
brian
thanks uh and joseph do we know yet how
these children died based on all the
facts so far
uh they're you know facts are let's say
the cause of death has not been
specifically named
uh you know i have a few ideas but i
want to talk about another tom
i want to talk about another timeline we
had mentioned uh
this court trial and i've seen a lot of
chatter on social media about how long
this is going to take and this sort of
thing
but let's talk about the timeline as it
applies to the crime
itself when you begin to break this down
and you think about
the idea that they impeded the
investigation
they hampered the investigation they
maybe
covered up evidence or destroyed
evidence this is key in forensics brian
this is
this is the underpinning of what we do
because as i teach my students at
jacksonville state
crime investigation forensic
investigation works in linear time
so the further you move down the track
relative to
that event that horrible homicides we're
assuming that this is homicides
that have taken place the more evidence
beguns begins to be lost obscured
destroyed all these sorts of things and
that's why this is such a critical
charge in this case
think about how long it was before these
bodies were actually discovered
you know we're talking about changes in
the soil the environment
and not to mention the bodies themselves
these bodies are severely decomposed
not to mention we have picked up on
evidence
that there was an attempt to destroy uh
kaley's body in particular
by fire so this is going to compromise
the integrity of the evidence so this is
big news this is something that we need
to watch very carefully
because all kinds of things have been
lost along the way and i can tell you
that's why prosecutors are after her for
this
let's hope not too much has been lost
jsm thank you for that
attorneys for two of the shooting
victims during protests in kenosha
wisconsin
are filing negligence claims the claims
filed on behalf of two men
one who survived and one who was
murdered says the city and the county
were negligent in their response
to the unrest protesters took to the
streets this summer over the police
shooting of jacob blake
then 17-year-old kyle rittenhouse is
accused of shooting three people
and is facing five felony charges rent
house expected in court for his
arraignments
on tuesday lawyers for two of the men
charged with shooting an unarmed jogger
in georgia don't want him to be called a
victim in their trial
gregory and travis mcmichael are accused
of murdering 25 year old ahmad aubrey
in february attorneys for the mcmichaels
say using the term
victim quote allows the focus to shift
to the accused
rather than remain on the proof of every
element of the crimes charged
former homicide prosecutor and law and
crime legal analyst bernardo violona
says there's a middle ground for how to
refer to aubry
the defendant is entitled to a fair
trial so in order for there to be a fair
trial in this case i believe it is right
for ahmad aubry to be referred to not as
the victim but more of let's refer to
him as the deceased
we're talking about a person that was
killed we are talking about the defense
saying that they killed a mod aubry in
self-defense
so that being the case the legalization
of the term
victim is hence already making the
decision
for the jury when the jury is supposed
to be the fact finder and to determine
who was the actual victim in this case
and again you know i'm putting emotions
aside when i say this because i truly
believe ahmad arby was the victim in his
case
however in a court of law he should be
referred to as a deceased
i would gently disagree he is a victim
the only question is whether or not it's
self-defense but we'll continue with
that later
still ahead on law and crime daily how
the death of a serial killer impacts
justice for his victims
and later all prosecutors rushed to hold
on to video in the robert craft case
why the now closed sex crimes case
against the new england patriots owner
is still making headlines
one of america's most prolific serial
killers has passed away
long crime daily's angenette levy spoke
with a prosecutor
who interviewed little about two murders
he committed in ohio
yeah brian the fbi says samuel little
actually murdered 93 people mostly women
in 19 states from 1970 until
2005. now little was actually arrested
over the years for other crimes but he
was never
caught for murder because he said he
left town after killing a woman
and then dumping her body little
maintained his innocence
until after his conviction in california
and a texas ranger interviewed him in
prison
that ranger james holland got little to
admit to murdering 93 people
always by strangling holland got little
to also
sketch his victims many of whom were
prostitutes
in the hope of identifying them little
could recall a lot of details about the
women he killed
she's a black male dressed up as a
female
okay how tall is is she mary about five
seven zero five six
she weighed about one thirty
five okay one maybe one four
and how old do you think she was but she
was 19.
okay and where was she from
no miami down in liberty city
now little also confessed to killing two
women from the cincinnati ohio area one
of those women was identified the other
has never been found her remains are
still out there somewhere and police
have yet to identify
her prosecutors and police are working
to do that and i actually spoke with one
of the prosecutors who interviewed
little in prison
about what motivated him
this was his life number one he um
one thing about samuel little too i've
tried a number of serial killers
um and most of them just like ooze evil
that's just the only way to describe
them and sam little was not like that he
was very
it sounds sunny funny saying this about
him but he was personable he was
congenial he was
he would kid around he said do you think
it's wrong for a man to have sexual
intercourse with a woman
i said no he goes well to me putting my
hands around a woman's throat and
choking her
that was my form of sex there's all
kinds of different sex
to me that was sex and it's like
you know dude you're weird but that's
that's the way he looked at it the rest
of it meant
nothing to him you could have a
supermodel in the back seat with him
naked and it would do nothing for him
until
he started choking her out and then
that's when he got aroused a renowned
forensic death investigator and
jacksonville state university professor
joseph scott morgan joins us he's been
following the case
and joseph there have been 50 of these
confessions that have been verified
by law enforcement that leaves about 43
homicides
unsolved to date you know they say
little was very good with details but
there are some other details that are
sketchy with him because of the sheer
number and volume
of these murders so what chance do you
see in the rest of these murders being
solved
i gotta tell you one of the fascinating
things about samuel little's case
is is that we have dna evidence from him
and you know moving you know when i
think back to things like
uh you know uh henry lee lucas and audis
tool who were a pair
that traveled all over the country had a
lot of freedom and they worked in tandem
they lied about a lot of the cases but
they did commit a lot of cases
we don't have we don't have that much
dna but for him we have a source
material for him
uh particularly if he's engaging in
fantasy activities with the body
and they were able to collect that at
the time this is a living person
uh now that we have this attached to so
as the database increases and it
improves and i'm thinking
uh primarily through things like
familial dna we might have
a better chance of solving some of these
open cases and confirming
some of the things that he has said
along the way let's
think about what this ranger has has
accomplished it's mind-blowing
and i agree with the prosecutor he's
he's almost affable
when you listen to him talk i listen to
several minutes of
of the interviews and he goes into
fine detail about clothing hair color
he kept using the term which i found
fascinating when he was talking about
the tone of skin
he said yeah that girl was honey color
and he used that term over and over
again and it's
it's striking because a lot of these
guys have these very vivid fantasy lives
in their mind and
he's living this over and over even
cases that happened
all the way back in the early 70s it's
still happening
it was still happening in real time as
he was talking to this ranger
yeah and we've definitely seen that in
this case and hopefully there will be
some justice provided to the victims
and their families joseph scott morgan
thanks again so much for talking with us
with us about this brian we're going to
send it back to you thanks angenet as
well as joseph scott morgan
coming up on law and crime daily why a
teen convicted of posing as a fake
doctor
is back behind bars plus the dramatic
body cam video of police rescuing a girl
from drowning in freezing water the
video you don't want to miss
next
[Music]
the search for a missing three-year-old
boy is continuing as his mother's
boyfriend remains in custody
on charges in connection with her murder
desean brown waived his arraignment for
murder
gross abuse of a corpse and tampering
with evidence prosecutors say he killed
neticia lattimore in early december and
dumped her body near a bridge
her son nilo has been missing ever since
and police say foul play is suspected
the search and rescue team are still out
looking for him
and report finding his stroller and a
bag with possible blood on it
in addition to our normal uh ground
units
and k-9 units we brought in
mounted units as well to help cover the
territory
some of this terrain is pretty dense and
difficult
and the horses can maybe make a pathway
plus they sit up they have an advantage
they're up higher
so it's just an additional tool
a federal judge has ruled that the
execution of a female inmate
can proceed lisa montgomery was set to
be executed last month
but that was delayed because her lawyers
contracted covent 19.
montgomery was convicted of using a
kitchen knife to cut out an
eight-month-old fetus out of a woman's
womb
to try to raise it as her own the victim
was found dead in a pool of blood
the baby survived and was returned to
its father her execution is now
scheduled for january 12th
and she'll be the first female inmate
executed in 70 years
law and crime host bob bianchi explains
possible issues in the appeals court
ruling
i've had a big problem with this as a
person who has tried death penalty cases
and handled them as a prosecutor i am
not an advocate of it any longer only
because i've seen the system
uh sometimes being so wildly
inconsistent
and here by my calculations eight
days eight days could be the difference
between whether somebody is executed or
not
now i understand that our audience is
gonna say she should burn
in hell for everything she and i
understand that sentiment what i don't
like is the arbitrariness
of this the lawyers argued that the
clemency petition is in a vital
important part of the criminal justice
process
and they should have the ability to file
it and potentially file appeals of
something of some nature
which would push it over that arbitrary
line of january 20th
it's literally the difference between
life or death
dramatic police body cam video captured
the moments officers rescued a
six-year-old girl
after her mother allegedly attempted to
drown her
look someone get a car and take the kids
baltimore police say the mother was
having a mental health crisis
and was trying to kill herself and her
daughter officers jumped into the
freezing inner harbor water
to pull both of them out the
six-year-old was unconscious and
unresponsive
she was rushed to the hospital and
doctors were able to save her life
both mother and daughter are recovering
when we come back
was the estate of prince undervalued by
half its worth
we look into new allegations by the irs
filed in court
after the break
[Music]
the 18 doctor known as dr love has been
arrested for fraud again
malachi love robinson pled guilty in
2018 to setting up a fraudulent holistic
medical practice
and scamming an elderly woman out of 20
000
when he was just 18 years old it seems
like he's back to his old tricks
investigators say that since his release
from prison love-robinson has been
working as a shipping broker and
apparently had clients send money to his
personal account
instead of the company police say he
took over ten thousand dollars and
texted the owner of the company that he
quote
effed up the legal battle over the
estate of legendary performer and
musician prince
is continuing with new claims from the
irs according to court documents the irs
believes prince's state
is worth 160 million dollars that's more
than
double the valuation by the estate's
administrator co-america bank and trust
prince died in 2016 from a fentanyl
overdose
and did not have a will the discrepancy
is mostly over the value of prince's
music publishing
and recording interests the irs believes
prince's estate owes more than 30
million dollars in federal taxes
about double its current bill terry
co-america has asked the tax court to
hold a trial to resolve the issue
how do you see that playing out you know
what first of all brian i say
please let prince rest in peace having
said that
i'm not surprised the irs wants to
assert that the estate
is worth more so they can tax more but i
think
battling this out in court is not the
answer it's a waste of the assets of the
estate
and the parties should really submit
their expert valuations
to an impartial mediator who can
equitably
split the difference so that's what i
think should happen in this case
it does sound like a better plan terry
and now to florida where a prosecutor is
asking a judge
to preserve video that allegedly shows
new england patriots owner robert kraff
paying for a sex act craft faced charges
after secret police surveillance cameras
at a massage parlor
allegedly caught men paying for
prostitution but both a trial judge and
an appeals judge
ruled the sting operation violated
legitimate patrons rights to privacy
the video was suppressed and now kraft
defense team wants it destroyed
altogether
palm beach county prosecutor dave
ehrenberg says
he was forced to drop the charges in
september because the video couldn't
come in
as evidence the jupiter police
department
did the right thing in pursuing the
investigation and i stand behind the
decision
to file the cases the orchids of asia
day spa
was a notorious brothel in a family
shopping center right next to a game
room that attracted children
rich guys from a local country club
lined up to receive sex acts throughout
the day
until the place closed around midnight
although we could not prove human
trafficking beyond
a reasonable doubt there was evidence of
human trafficking in the overall
investigation terry the prosecutor says
he has no interest in preserving the
video but there's still a pending
lawsuit
where it might come into evidence how do
you think that court will rule
well you know brian that's right there's
a separate class action on the 42 usc
1983 and that was filed by some
unnamed individuals and it gives them
the right to
sue a state employee under the color of
state law for civil rights violations
and i actually think that the case is
going to prevail as far as the state
attorney is concerned because i don't
think that they are going to
allow this evidence to be destroyed so
you're basically saying that this video
may at some point in time in a different
case
see the light of day that's right brian
they cannot actually understate law
destroy evidence when there could be a
potential lawsuit and here we know for a
fact
that there is a pending lawsuit so i
don't think that the judge is going to
say
destroy the evidence i think the judge
is duty-bound as are the parties
to preserve the evidence for this
potential trial
which is actually a pending case yeah
that makes a lot of sense because of
course you can't
turn back the dials to get that video
afterwards
it could be good for the case but i
don't know if seeing that video is going
to be good for the rest of us
terry thanks for joining us and of
course thank you for joining us here at
long crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you